senior year of high school we have this
massive falling out where he ends up
falling in love with my girlfriend and I
caught a letter to him in my
girlfriend's stuff of her saying sorry
we can't be together whoa
[Music]
what is something that you let someone
borrow and you never saw it again
four hundred dollars 400. you lent
someone 400 bucks yes dude it used to be
in our Squad his name it starts with the
V starts with the T oh checked her
tyke song
eighty dollars from a coin jar never saw
it again what do you mean eighty dollars
for a coin me and Nikki had a coin jar
we had been saving up our entire
relationship which at this point I
believe was six years in did you have
roommates or something wait you lent
someone eighty dollars and they just
never mentioned paying you back well
they were they were high and they asked
to borrow it and then they never paid it
back because maybe they're high they
forgot that they even modeled it yeah
there are they were shrooming it pretty
hard and what happened to this 400 what
was the reason they wanted 400 bucks so
it was one dude in our Squad he uh well
no longer one of the few people that
have been
uh yeah good thing you have plenty of
members we we needed to do a gig and we
needed a uh we needed uh to go
International so everybody needed to
have their passport situation ready to
go right so then this guy didn't have
his passport ready to go it was like
expired or whatever the [__] excuse
it was uh but he also didn't have a car
to go to the passport center and stuff
like that so I had to like go pick his
ass up take him to a passport center I'd
also spot and pay for the passport that
was expedited because he didn't mention
any of this issue until like just like
seven days before like needing fired
some random [__] like that which means
it's more expensive and you got to pay
the shipping and all this stuff right
and uh he was like yeah dude I'll pay
you back blah blah after the gig and all
this stuff but then it also turned into
like after the game getting paid he's
like yo like I don't got money to eat
for like this blah blah and I need to
cover this stuff and why is he so
irresponsible wait so he's is he like
asking for money to eat too yeah he's
like and I'll pay you back after but
realistically like this guy's so
irresponsible that he also had like
Warren sound [__] didn't pay for certain
tickets and what and got caught with
like drugs stuff and had to go to jail
for a couple days and stuff instead of
showing it to rehearsal so it was a
whole bit he was hooked on something
yeah it was why he's no longer yeah when
you're hooked on drugs you know that
becomes your priority unfortunately yeah
but you never bothered to like like you
just know you'll never see it again so
you just oh 100 damn what
um are you okay am I finished yeah
because I didn't want to interrupt you
oh no thank you for asking that yeah
it's very polite yeah he hadn't said
anything for like eight seconds oh
I just have a 10 second roll all right I
see I said yeah wait a little longer
that's the Golden Rule good job that
happened to you
no I was giving you 10 seconds before I
say anything okay
Okay so
so
um my friend who was playing pool and
then they were betting with another like
a random person in a bar yeah and then
my friend didn't have he does a lot of
okay oh and um but so he borrowed 40
dollars to play the other person yeah
but then they won but oh and then I was
like hey let me get them after like let
me get that 40 back and I was I was
grabbing it from his hand he's like I'll
give it back to you later and then and
then he just never gave it back but he
won though yeah he won it so I was like
let me get it back real quick to so to
get drinks or something he's like yeah
yeah I'll give it back to you later and
then I think that night I asked him
twice and I just didn't ask him again
but he didn't give it back to me but how
do you what would you what I have would
I have done because he's a friend that
I've known for a long time just say his
name right now yeah I would be like no
dude that's crazy the second time if he
doesn't give me back that money we're
yelling at each other and possibly
tickling each other not a friend friend
though just like a acquaintance like
you've known him for a long time but you
see him like you know once a year weird
I would just cut him out of my life yeah
I don't know I will I'll be like once a
year I'd be like that's not a I'm not
asking you that's my money give it back
to me and then but then it's weird too
because sometimes wool um like that same
trip will have drinks and then he'll pay
for it one time do I mean yeah and then
he'll be loud he's paying it for your
money that's different yeah he's paying
for the drinks from your money that he
borrowed from you yeah or like in a cab
he'll be like oh okay I got it but I'm
like yeah so it's like were you using my
money yeah that's different that's weird
do it that's really weird that's really
weird what if you go hey can I borrow 40
bucks to place a bet all right thank you
hey I just got these drinks and he's
like let me get that and like I'll take
the cash thanks yeah yeah
I hate when people try to play ignorant
to like get you to stop asking though
yeah that's that's always really weird
I had a really prolonged
uh where I thought I lost out on like
two grand
but I finally got it so like um I was
trying to get these rims from a friend
and my friend he was like super into
like the uh like car scene like as cars
featured in magazines and stuff so he
always has all these connections to like
all kinds of car parts
and then so he recently told me like oh
I have I have connection to this one
wheel company and I can get it for like
50 off I'm oh [__] sick so I took my
financial aid money and I was gonna
spend it all on the on the wheels so he
can link me up with the dude
and um I gave him the money and it's one
of those where it's custom made to the
car so after I gave because it's like
four inch wheels you know so it's like
two piece yeah so I gave him the money
and they they told me it's gonna wait
like three months and then when they're
like 21 or 22 whatever that feels like
[__] forever you know so I was
probably the guy that was like every
week like on the wheels done yet my
wheels down and my wheels done yet and
he ends up ghosting me and I'm like oh
[__] what the [__] does an answer damn
and I tell my friend to ask ask him and
then so now he's being relay in the
middle and then so things still get
dragged out and then I started to like
get pissed because it was like I think
it was like 2 000 or 2500 and then I was
like I know his parents own a restaurant
on uh Garvey oh my do I need to like
[__] trash that place to get my money
back I'm like what the [__] do I need
that's some Triad level of things I need
to do something because I don't want him
to think I'm a [__] or anything either
it'll be disrespected yeah and then and
I'm like [__] all this for Wheels I'm
also trying to turn my life around uh
yeah too messy I'll turn around after
getting my wheels yeah how can you turn
around without them
exactly it and then it got and then
finally he calls me randomly he goes oh
we just don't didn't know what your
offset was or whatever it's like okay
cool I'm gonna go measure my [__]
Wheels I'm in my wheel well and I told
him to offset and then goes to me again
I'm like what the [__] is this fool
dragging me along is he just doing the
waiting game where he just is waiting
for me to just Sizzle out and he steals
my money and then after almost eight
months
um he calls me and he goes your wheels
are at this shop
and uh what's weird is I thought this
guy was really tight with my friend so I
thought he would be one of those like
hey I hooked you up let's put on your
wheels let's look at it together and be
[__] sick I go to the shop
he's not there he just goes hey this uh
this some guy just told me that you're
these are your wheels these are your
wheels oh wow so I guess he's he's still
fully delivered it
but a month late sure like yeah really
late and I was able to put it on the car
I just never uh I was I thought I was
like this close to [__] like not just
losing out on like 2 500 bucks which is
crazy so it's just no answer not of
nowhere yeah so I don't even know what
happened and then through that that guy
was also not friends with my other
friend anymore it was just weird and you
trashed his parents restaurant I didn't
know that I didn't did I do that okay I
didn't do that yeah we had a good
catfish soup there though it's a
Vietnamese restaurant you know
Vietnamese did like the catfish soup
with the pineapples and stuff it was
really good there sour soup yeah
I remember one of my first
um feelings of like this is this is
where you can't trust people is like we
had this art book like back in a day we
would have like a peace book because
you're a graffiti artist yeah right and
you have this like you have all of your
pieces and [__] and then like you would
start passing this around you trade it
with people yeah and you trade it and
you write it up and then so like this
one kid was like yeah I need a couple
more days like can I take it home
because it would be during class too
that we would do it took it home and
then I was like dude you're taking a
long ass time and he goes oh yeah it's
with this dude now so I'm like what so I
go up and I and I'm like yo you have the
you have the book why do you have the
book and he goes oh yeah I'm gonna put a
piece in it all right cool cool and I
weigh like another and it just keeps
getting passed around I never get my
[__] book back right and I'm all like
what the [__] dude why is it taking so
long I had a lot of dope [__] in there
from so many different artists and then
at the end of it
I think it like it got lost or something
happened and I was like I want my
[__] book back and then the I guess
the guy at the very end of the chain was
like to be honest man it got jacked oh
and then he's like and I don't know like
it's it's what happened to me like
passed around it happened to the person
that kept passing it around and that by
that time it's like no one took
responsibility or yeah and then it was
just gone and I was just like man like I
didn't even
say they can let other people pass it
and borrow it and then in my head I'm
like man I I can't like let things go
like that you know like you just don't
know like there's been so many incidents
where you like trust people and you're
like yeah you could borrow this like and
it started from like junior high high
school all that like it was until I went
to like Christian School we went to
where it was like people were more
honorable yeah but like people borrowing
[__] and never giving it back that
starts hella early yeah especially yeah
I always thought people would give it
back
and they never give it back never been
what happened to you too yeah yeah well
I this one time um this is not the
giving back one but this is out so I was
in a car in downtown San Diego and uh um
there's a homeless guy who came knocked
on the window and I was like I don't
want it whatever the thing is and he
shows me a laptop
do you know this one no he's not just
funny how he has a laptop yeah well it's
in a box and just oh it's brand new yeah
it's in a box yeah and then it I rolled
down the window I was like what is it
and my friend works at Sony so he's so
he's like hey do you want this laptop
I'll sell it to you for cheap I was like
no because it's not a laptop and then uh
he goes no this is literally brand new
and then my friend looks at it he's like
no this is legit and I didn't want it to
get it because I was like nah this is
weird you know what I mean homeless
laptop and I was like well where'd you
get it and then this is why I got it he
was like oh it's because it was I stole
it from a back of a UPS truck or a FedEx
truck I also got it this is so honest
yeah it's because of this so he goes I
stole them from finisher I was like okay
then this is real
because you were more worried about if
it was fake versus if he stole it yeah I
don't give a [__] what you got it from
you got a laptop and it's really nice I
wanted laptop for cheap and then he's
like okay it's a 160 dollars I was like
I was like all right but I don't have
that but can't go to the bank well let's
go together so the homeless guy's in the
car with you no no no well I was like
it's just down the street he walks over
there okay and then with my friend and
um
uh I I took out the money but then I
didn't have
I think I had like two or three hundred
dollars but I didn't want to give him
160. so I was like hey can you do it for
80. he's like ah all right and then um I
got it and then we opened it up it was
books inside
yeah but then it was perfectly it had
[__] wait so your friend was like
it's a real laptop
yeah I did it unbelievable wow I never
got that back I hope they were bad books
too I hope it was like Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone it wasn't it was
like wait so it was a laptop I'm not a
big Harry Potter God seven circles of
designs and your friend didn't open it
to check because he said that it's he's
certified you're on the outside he
looked it up he's like yeah this is good
wow cool dude remind me to take you with
me to my deals in the future dude thanks
your friend owed you money frankly
there was um uh so the the very first
one on one b-boy tournament that I ever
won it was on this tape and on that same
tape was the very first three on three
b-boy tournament that I ever won and I
lent it to my friend and his girl was
mad at him and record it over the tape
oh my god oh oh my God because she knew
that that would make me mad at him oh my
God what a crazy [__] thing how
[__] is that man this is her
absolutely insane wow
it's footage from 2002 that and I'll
never have it again because she was just
mad at him
and I had to wrap me up in it yeah it
sucks what the [__] that's like next how
do you think of strategies like that I
know that's a crazy a little impressed I
don't know she was she was tied so maybe
that had something to do with it we tied
you mentally I used to collect baseball
cards right yeah and I remember um I
would pick out you know I remember
hearing at the time that like rookie
cards were hot around kids at school
right so I was like okay I'll pick out
all the rookie cards I get so every time
I got baseball cards I pulled out the
rookie cards I just threw them all into
the sand binder
so buy like you know a whole couple
years like five years later I have Ken
Griffey Jr's rookie card I have Sean
Kemp from these Seattle SuperSonics
rookie card uh SuperSonics rookie card I
have like all these like [__] fire
ass athletes who are coming up at the
time rookie card
and then uh I was stupid though and I
told a bunch of people that
and then the next thing I know like
because you know you have people over
and stuff like that
my binder's gone my rookie card binder
is gone gone gone look in every room in
the house every nook and cranny of the
house gone gone gone so I I narrowed it
down as one of the few kids in my
neighborhood but someone made off with a
nice little collection definitely worth
thousands just straight jacket from your
jacket for me yeah yeah well not from my
room for my basement but yeah that's
where I kept it
damn but I was dumb I learned early on
not to run your [__] mouth yeah like
that like that oh yeah that would happen
all the time like when you have friends
over and then like sometimes there's
just new people yeah like and there's
like a lot of people where he's having a
blast and then like your GI yo goes
missing yep and then like some [__] goes
missed it's always something that it's
like where did it go oh it must be that
one new kid that came over I like the
idea Steve like I learned a long time
ago not to run my [__] mouth
meanwhile has got like
a corner Come and Get It [__]
I got guns now dude I just remembered
there was um so like as a kid I
collected the 80s Nintendo games like
the cartridges and uh as they got
cheaper over time because one Super
Nintendo came out the price on regular
Nintendo went down a lot so you I was
finally able to buy them myself I ended
up with over 100 games by by the time I
was in high school like I would just
keep buying them
um my best friend at the time senior
year of high school wanted to borrow
them like the system and then he's like
oh yeah I just want to play some old
school games they're like yeah why not I
don't even play that anymore I play
PlayStation now I play superintendo like
I play n64. so I didn't mean a lot much
to me to lend him the system he starts
asking for more and more games to the
point where he ends up having pretty
much all my games at his house and it's
my best friend so I'm like whatever
nothing could ever come between us that
I would never see this stuff again
senior year of high school we have this
massive falling out where he ends up
falling in love with my girlfriend and I
caught a letter to him in my
girlfriend's stuff of her saying sorry
we can't be together whoa
oh yes so we had this massive falling
out so she was double dating no she
basically he fell in love with her on
the side and then he was trying to like
confess to her one day yeah behind my
back and then she uh was declining it in
a letter and I found the letter in her
room randomly there's no loyalty in that
in that age yeah Nintendo 2 both things
and he stole your Nintendo well she
didn't like she didn't do anything with
him she was just basically like I'm so
sorry I I can't do this we can't be
talking like it was like a rejection
letter but like dude I had no clue that
was happening and then so I bet you had
Earthbound but did you get your games
back you know so what happened is like I
went basically went over to his house to
like kick his ass uh and then he I think
he knew when his brothers opened it up
and they were just like not letting me
in and then oh that's just when I knew I
was like I'll never see any of my [__]
again did you have EarthBound
this is regular Nintendo so it was a
Bubble Bobble yeah yeah that was it I
hope you didn't take the punch out
either he took most of my I still have
maybe like 25 cartridges from that OG
Donkey Kong but almost 100 games are
gone and then I think years later when
we finally just [__] patched it up
like a decade later you patched it that
that yeah because because one of our
good friends in our Circle has his
mother passed away and we were at the
funeral and he came up to me he was just
like I'm so sorry about everything buy
me my [__] Nintendo yeah and then I
asked him about that and he said that
his dad threw it out or something
[__] no way what's his name dude
what's his eBay salesman account
yeah it was it was it was a bad bad
thing but I mean I could see that
because it was worthless at the time no
nobody thought those things would go up
in price anymore yeah yeah I feel like
everyone should learn the hard lesson of
trust like just letting people borrow
[__] and them not taking care of because
I can't fathom it because like I've
borrowed stuff from people and then I'll
give it back yeah 100 and especially if
they ask or if I if I'm like I even get
worried if I held it too long yeah you
get stressed out that's why I'm like
yeah you get anxiety yeah but it should
happen to to people so you understand
that there are low lives out there that
don't give a [__] about your things I
remember learning it maybe in I think
like third grade where you start having
like your favorite pencil and whatever
and I remember someone borrowing it and
then yeah and then the next day like oh
can I have it back and like I don't have
any more and you're just like yeah
you're talking about
[Laughter]
it doesn't even occur you're like wait
how did you lose that
if I borrow anything I'll bring it I'm
bringing it back tomorrow right away for
you yeah but then the smart kid who's
like a future car salesman he's like
well I kept using it and then I kept on
having to sharpen it and then
it's gone what do you want me to give
you an eraser
a metal ring it's good logic okay I
guess he used it you're like all right
fine just give me back the Eraser yeah
exactly that's a guy that can sell
exactly that's a closer he's a closer
for sure